no this is not a John wick spin-off has
nothing to do with John wick I saw the
trailer I was like oh nope it's a new
thing
[Music]
Hotel Artemus so hotel Artemus is a
movie that takes place in the future and
Jodie Foster runs this hotel called
hotel Arnhem she's also a nurse and so
what will happen as criminals get
wounded and if you're a member of the
hotels Club you can get in and it's a
super secret place that'll patch you up
the movie has solid enjoyment in it most
of that comes from Jodie Foster and the
environment as a whole Jodie Foster
really does carry a lot of this movie
though it's just for her it's just
non-stop she's going to this room this
room that room that room trying to stop
the people from breaking into the hotel
all the while maintaining the rules but
essentially she patches of criminals
she's super sweet lady it's just that
gray area things aren't so
black-and-white in life I enjoy the fact
that Jodie Foster's character is a super
nice lady who's basking in that gray
area also she in the place she runs
super stickler for rules and that's a
hook for me I always like it when a
place like this heals with criminals and
criminal organization but we have rules
here
can't kill each other you can't fight
each other just a list of rules you
might run into some enemies in these
hallways don't think twice about it in
that the hotel in general it brought me
into its Laura brought me into its world
other than Jodie Foster the movie more
or less revolves around sterling K Brown
can we just address the fact and
appreciate the fact that he's named
after a silver brief like a knight but
from him essentially spearheading the
guests of this hotel the development
starts going down as you go down the
list Erlin K Brown less for sofia
boutella
less for Charlie Day less for Jeff
Goldblum it does go down from there
Batista's in the movie to he's
essentially her security he's great if
you're gonna have a big security guy in
this movie make us chuckle a couple
times he does that movie is not always
so polished though if you really take a
moment to deconstruct this thing it
doesn't hold up I don't think it's
supposed to though it's supposed to be a
cheesy 90s action movie I feel like this
movie was actually written in the 90s
and then sat on a shelf until now and so
it was like oh well that's old let's
make this but in movies like this that
are supposed to be 90s action cheese are
you supposed to have a myriad of things
just kind of slide under the radar there
are a couple of moments when you stop
and think about it just character
moments
like that doesn't make sense doesn't
matter if it's supposed to be 90s action
cheese that thing doesn't make sense
that that character did one example with
no spoilers the fact that the main
character goes to his brother he's like
we need to get out of here now there's
someone here and we don't want him to
know we're here but in the hotel with a
lot of rules I'm pretty sure you can
just hunker down in your room and he
granted something does happen that
escalates the situation and yeah they
probably should leave at that point but
before that happens he starts freaking
out and he kind of I felt like he got
ahead of the plot has one action
sequence in a hallway two is a fight
sequence I really enjoyed the hell out
of that like after daredevil season one
everyone was truly like fights in a
hallway folks that's what sells that
let's do that also the only action
sequence so don't look for this isn't
really an action movie it's a hey let's
navigate this undesirable situation and
keep it from being a high-tension
scenario back this movie does feel
compartmentalized when it comes to the
characters I could have gone for a
moment where everyone was in a room they
were like alright I hate you and I can't
fight you but the plot of this entire
movie is hey we don't want them to know
we're here no one can know that this
lady's here it's so it really deals with
no one can know that anyone's in this
hotel stay for a couple of people who do
interact most people in this movie did a
great job I thought sterling K Brown was
great as the lead of the guests in the
hotel sofia boutella doesn't always have
the roles that I feel showcases a badass
character but this is one of the more
memorable roles she's had our other day
was great as a scumbag and Jeff Goldblum
the movie literally gets better when he
steps on screens like I said I could
have gone for more development for some
of those characters but for the actors
the actors did their part while the
character I didn't like with Zachary
Quintos character I think it's a mix of
Zachary Quintos character in the movie
just wasn't written well and didn't do
much he did that thing people do
sometimes worse like I'm playing a
villain so I have to talk intense every
syllable just needs always be intense
open the [ __ ] door you don't need to
be like that the super cool villain in
this movie a hundred times more menacing
than that but in the end hotel Artemus I
really dug it you're gonna give me a
90's action movie that would have been
right at home in the 90s just commit to
it this movie committed in the end
walked out of this movie with a smile on
my face I will say Hotel Artemis is a
good time no alcohol requires a
self-aware movie it's rare these days
it's just a rare thing grace a hotel
Artemus have you seen it why did you
about it or what's your favorite 90s
movie or 90's action movie that didn't
actually come out in the 90s whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]